- [Narrator] For the last five years,
New York's LaGuardia Airport
has been undergoing an $8 billion upgrade.
And according to the Port
Authority of New York
and New Jersey,
its transformation will
be complete next spring.
- The old airport,
which was probably one of
the most hated airports
in the country will have been transformed
into one of the best.
- [Narrator] But rebuilding
an entire airport
while keeping it functional
for up to 50,000 passengers
on busy days is no easy feat.
So how did the Port Authority pull it off
and what can travelers
expect going forward?
Renovating LaGuardia Airport
involved tearing down
and rebuilding every
single passenger facility
with the exception of the
landmark Marine Air Terminal.
And since it remained an active airport,
renovations had to be
done one area at a time.
- The construction pattern had to be
that you build a new passenger facility.
You put that into use
and it was then, and only then
that you could tear down the old.
- [Narrator] The pandemic
brought challenges,
such as having to enforce
strict safety protocols
for workers on the construction project.
But the drop in passengers
did make it easier
to construct new roadways.
- You could actually confine the traffic
to individual lanes
so that construction on the
new terminals could accelerate
because you could use those for cranes,
for other construction equipment.
- [Narrator] The Port
Authority says the airport
is currently about halfway
through renovations,
and so far, there have been
some positive reactions.
- We've heard from pilots,
we've heard from airline staff.
I've actually been in the airport
when passengers come out of a jet way
having just got off of a plane
where they do a complete double take
and say, "Did I get on
the wrong airplane?"
- [Narrator] Terminal B is 90% finished,
and features art, greenery,
four airline lounges
and 42 new shops and restaurants.
The Port Authority says
that one key difference
between the old and new Terminal B
is that almost all of
the shops and restaurants
are located after security,
so travelers can shop and dine
while waiting for their flights.
There's also a sky bridge
that allows passengers to
walk over active taxi ways.
- As you drive up to the airport
on the departures level,
you will see an extraordinary vista
of the Manhattan skyline.
There's one brand new concourse,
which is quite striking.
It looks out both on Flushing
Bay and on City Field.
- [Narrator] Terminal
C, which is being built
by Delta Airlines is
set to open next spring.
All of the new passenger facilities
have also moved closer
to the main highway.
This way, aircrafts
have more space to taxi
and there could be fewer
issues getting to their gate.
- Now we're seeing an airport emerge,
which is what the region deserves,
what travelers deserve,
what employees of all of the employers
at the airport deserve.
(lively music)